now in a historic shift away from
neutrality both finland and sweden have
taken steps towards joining nato the
move is prompted by concern for their
own security in the wake of russia's
invasion of ukraine but there is one
problem nato member turkey could use its
veto power to block the expansion
it's a radical break with the past one
that was almost unimaginable just months
ago in finland's capital helsinki prime
minister sana marin announced the
country's decision to apply to join nato
after decades of non-alignment
we have reached today an important
decision in good cooperation between the
government and the president of the
republic
we hope that the parliament will confirm
the decision to apply for nato
membership during the coming days
it will be based on a strong mandate
finland shares a border of over 1 000
kilometers with russia after russia
invaded ukraine public opinion based in
part on fears that its eastern neighbor
would do the same to finland moved
strongly in favor of joining nato
this happened as foreign ministers from
the military alliance's member countries
met in berlin
nato's secretary general appeared at
that meeting via video link
he welcomed finland's decision and
encouraged sweden to follow
this would be an historic moment
their membership in nato would increase
our shared security
demonstrate that nato's door is open
and that aggression
does not pay
the meeting's host german foreign
minister annalena berbach added an
enthusiastic note
schwein on finland if you are ready we
are ready
soon after sweden's prime minister
answered the call russia's unprovoked
invasion of ukraine is not only illegal
and indefensible
it also undermines the european security
order that sweden builds its security on
as a member of nato sweden will not only
achieve more security but also
contribute to more support to more
security one potential problem turkey
has expressed reservations about letting
the two nordic countries join ankara
blames them for sheltering kurdish
activists that turkey considers enemies
of the state
there should be absolute security
guarantees here this is not just about
two candidate countries but also about
allied states who need to stop
supporting terrorist organizations
but officials said they were certain
those differences could be resolved
quickly meanwhile nothing will change
right away the finnish parliament must
ratify the decision and the nato
application process could take up to a
year
and we can cross straight to brussels
now and speak to our correspondent there
christine mundo hi christine can you
walk us through what still needs to
happen before finland and sweden
officially apply to join nato
good morning anya so effectively nato
membership needs the unanimous approval
of all of the alliances 30 members and
what that means
is that every single member state has to
go to their parliament and have that
ratified and this is why this process
could take up two months for his part
the nato secretary general said both
sweden and finland would be welcomed
with open arms that the accession
process would be quick but in reality it
does look like it would take at least a
few months
before all those processes those former
processes can conclude in each member's
parliament
so it's going to take a while if
everyone agrees but how likely is it
that turkey could veto finland and
sweden's membership bid
well turkey's opposition does pose a
serious threat and as we've just heard
in the report there there does seem to
be confidence among the young other
members states um and and allies for
example the secretary general said he
was confident that they would find
common ground and reach consensus over
the matter but of course because nato
membership requires the unanimous
approval of every single member state if
turkey doesn't come to the table
that could effectively put a stop to
this process
now if finland and sweden do officially
apply to join nato other countries have
already made security assurances to the
two nations can you tell us a bit more
about that
that's right so nato has this principle
of if you attack one member you attack
every single of all the other members
right an attack on one is attacking
against all
that principle would not apply to sweden
and and finland until they become
members of the alliance so any security
guarantees
could not come from the alliance as a
collective but that member states would
have to step up and do that so for
example the united states as well as the
united kingdom have stepped up forward
this was uh when it was very clear that
uh both nordic countries were seriously
considering nato membership um for
example a british official said it was
unthinkable that britain wouldn't come
to to to either one of these countries
defense in the event that they did come
under attack for their part uh they are
thinking that this will provoke russia
uh to to perhaps um
target them
with cyber attacks or hybrid attacks
targeted specifically you know
propaganda campaigns and at russian
minority uh uh ethnic communities in in
their countries so that is the concern
and the united states in the united
kingdom uh two member states they have
really come out and said that they would
support both these countries in the
event of any such
dw's christine mundo in brussels thank
you so much
now in other developments in the ukraine
conflict
ukraine has accused russia of dropping
phosphorus bombs on the azov style steel
plant in mariopol images of the alleged
attack were released by a pro-russian
separatist commander the use of white
phosphorus is not banned under
international conventions but human
rights groups have called for it to be
outlawed because of the severe burns
that it causes
the ukrainian president vladimir
zelinski says negotiations on saving
ukrainian troops defending the as of
style plant are at a complicated and
delicate phase ukrainian sources say
some 1 000 people are holding out at the
site more than 80 days after the
invasion started they're refusing to
surrender to russian forces